I think wd-40 that makes wd-40 fantastic
company so in other words I'm tired of
people saying well it's you talk about
Apple it's easy for Apple cause it's
such a
I mean seriously wd-40 right that
company is phenomenal and they they
believe in coaching they believe in
taking care of their people they believe
in honesty they have a just cause it's
about creating memories for people I
know for Ana lubrication company and
they have trusting teams that people
stay there they don't leave because
there's all this all this additional
training that's offered to them they
believe anybody who's given any kind of
position of leadership is immediately
trained to be a coach they don't hire
outside coaches so that when people say
I'm struggling I made a mistake they
don't fix it for them they coach them
out of fix it themselves everybody feels
empowered to help and everybody feels
that somebody's there to help them it's
a remarkable company I've written about
barry-wehmiller it's a manufacturing
company in the Midwest remarkable
company many of the companies we love
tend to have that focus but some of them
lose it
Patagonia is still wonderful but
Container Store great you know but some
of them lose it
Walmart used to be infinite minded
Microsoft used to be infant minded I
think under satty it's trying to get
back what Ballmer broke I think it well
at Walmart what Doug McMillon is doing
is trying to get back what mike Duke
broke they the reason they're still
around is because they had a lot of
money I think the biggest challenge is
gonna be really from successes I think
an organization's biggest challenge
quite frankly because the pressures
become greater and all the people who've
been giving you money to help you grow
now want something back and it's the
flaw and the business model of private
equity and venture capital which is they
have to sell you have to sell they have
to sell to get money right and so they
can tell you all the flowery language
how much they love you and how much they
believe in your cause and till about
five years on average they need their
money back all of a sudden they don't
care as much and so then all that
amounts to is pressure we've forgotten
what an IPO really is supposed to be
you know when companies are growing
sometimes they want to raise money so
they can continue their growth continued
advance there just cause there's many
many ways to raise money you can ask
your friends and family you can take
investment from venture capital or
private equity you can get a loan from
the bank or you can sell some of your
equity and you can issue an IPO it's not
a mechanism to get rich it's a mechanism
to raise money for the company to
advance the cause we've forgotten that
and I think there's a lot of
well-meaning companies that are forced
to go public that going public is what
destroys them and their cultures worse
when you have these high-speed growth
companies and I don't understand why
we're obsessed with high-speed growth
there's only one thing in the world that
grows for the sake of growth and that's
cancer there has to be a purpose for
growth right there has to be a purpose
for growth what is the purpose for
growth and it should be to advance the
cause but if you're just growing for the
sake of growing to prove to somebody or
to make there's a gonna be a problem
it's gonna break growth is a dial it's
not an objective it's not a purpose you
know so if you're a retail operation and
you have a growth plan to open a hundred
stores this year but you're not spending
the time to hire the right people to
work in those stores and train them
properly you will open 100 stores that
are gonna fail growth is a dial so if
you see that you're not hiring good
people you adjust the dial we're only
gonna grow 20 stores so we can make sure
that we train the right people hire the
right people and get the right people in
the stores and then we'll worry about
the other in other words it's not it
doesn't matter what the year-end tells
you it's infinite the finite markers are
there for guidance it's like yes
metrics are important the finite is
important you can't run a marathon
without mile markers it's unnerving when
we don't know how fast or how far we've
gotten that's what metrics are that's
what goals are they tell a hat they tell
us how fast and how far but they're not
an indicator at the end of the game so
so I the the generally the companies
that we love doing business with
generally have elements of finite
mindset at this but it's it's like any
like any gym process it is a constant
it's constant it's not an event it's a
lifestyle it's not something you do it's
something you have to wake up every
to do like brushing your teeth you know
in companies like to solve problems with
intensity but this is about consistency
intensity is going to the dentist twice
a year like we're told but if that's all
you ever did your teeth are all gonna
fall out right
but intensity is scheduled we know what
we can expect you know we have that we
need leadership we have the company off
site we invite all the speakers we give
them a bunch of books everybody feels
great for a couple of weeks you didn't
make a bunch of leaders is that
necessary yes but that's not enough like
intensity is like I remembered her
birthday I bought her flowers in
Valentine's Day that should be enough
she'll fall in love with me you know
intensity is none of consistency is king
like brushing your teeth for two minutes
once in the morning once in the evening
that's what we're recommended
what does brushing your teeth do for two
minutes nothing unless you do it twice a
day every day
can I take in a day off because I'm too
tired yes yes you can
it'll do no damage how many days can I
take up I don't know and nor does any
dentist just don't do it too much
consistency is king what I'm talking
about is consistency and so every
organization that we admire struggles
with and tries to do these things
consistently which is much harder than
intensity intensity is foreshow
necessary sometimes but it's largely the
stuff we can see they make movies about
bad leaders they don't make movies about
good leaders right because it's about
intensity it's fun it's exciting
somebody comes in barks orders we all do
what they tell you say and we win the
battle do you know what a a well led
organization looks like it's boring
there's no movies about Eisenhower or
Marshall there's no movies about
Marshall he was amazing right you know
why because if you showed up in his
organization everybody's just working
things are just getting done
you say where's the boss they all go I
don't know he came in today like there's
a fire they just put it out it
no one's barking orders nobody screaming
they're just boring but they're
consistent so you you you we can feel it
you know it's the ones we admire the
hard part is can they stick to it and
and generally they don't because the
pressure gets them the courage is
lacking
[Music]
[Music]